[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à Lyon sur la place de Monplaisir
l'inauguration d'un monument aux frères
Lumière en présence d'Henri lumière qui
fut en 1894 le héros inconscient du
déjeuner de bébé ramène l'attention sur
cette invention qui fit depuis pas mal
de chemin le cinéma le monument se
dresse sous les fenêtres de la villa ou
les deux frères d'abord et Auguste salle
après la mort de son frère Louis
travailleur à mettre au point cette
découverte révolutionnaire et à côté des
ateliers où ils industrialisèrent leur
inventions détails curieux la vieille
entrée est restée ce qu'elle était
lorsqu'elle servit de décor au premier
film de tous les temps devenu
aujourd'hui une sorte de monument
historique la sortie des usines lumière
en tournant ce premier film Les Frères
Lumière avaient du même coup créé le
film d'actualité celui qui à travers les
grands événements et les détails
quotidiens a pour raison et pour devoir
décrire l'histoire c'est ainsi qu'on
peut retrouver grâce au cinéma du temps
l'atmosphère des inondations de 1910 et
avec ses serres gens de ville moustachu
et ses omnibus à chevaux l'ambiance d'un
pari d'avant la guerre de 14
avec ses duels aussi le duel faisant
alors partie de la chronique mondaine
avec ses présentations de mode ou le
Dior de l'époque qui s'appelait Paul
Poiret exhiber des élégances qui ne
contèrent pas pour rien dans les fastes
de la belle époque
[Musique]
on imagine pas de gaieté de cœur nos
belles amies pareillement costume
[Musique]
et quant au chapeau
mais dans l'actualité on vit encore le
vol du premier Zeppelin les premiers pas
des transports aériens
[Musique]
et gros plan historique la visite à
Berlin d'un Jaurès qui en juillet 1914
voulait encore ne pas croire à la guerre
le 14 à 18 l'actualité connue sur tous
les tranchées une guerre sans panache
avec seulement de la vermine de la boue
et de la mort et la caméra enregistra au
milieu des trous d'obus le triste
épisode des gaz asphyxiants
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
20 la victoire et l'actualité ce fut
cette page d'histoire extraordinaire
dans le décor des Champs-Élysées du
défilé derrière Foch et Joffre des
armées à lié
le reporter est toujours là aujourd'hui
sur ces mêmes Champs-Élysées il a un
enregistré pour le présent et pour
l'avenir le voyage en France du roi Olaf
5 de Norvège
[Musique]
devant la dalle du soldat inconnu le roi
et le général de Gaulle ont pu repenser
à cette fraternité d'armes qui se résume
dans le nom de Narvik
[Musique]
la visite du roi de Norvège devait se
terminer par une sorte d'à côté hausse à
l'Opéra
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
visite de l'amitié à laquelle la France
est sensible une amitié renforcée par
des traités mais aussi par un
attachement comme un à la liberté
[Musique]
et la caméra vanne et là également avec
les 30 000 spectateurs de Colomb pour
assister à un événement qui est Français
attendent depuis 36 ans la victoire de
leurs athlètes sont les athlètes
allemands cette victoire elle se dessine
déjà dès le 100 mètres qui constitue la
revanche des championnats d'Europe et
c'est de locaux qui cette fois prend le
meilleur le sprint français ne se porte
pas mal du tout il est le meilleur en
Europe en cette fin de saison après le
relais quatre fois 100 mètres personne
n'aurait osé parier un lien sur les
chances des Français avant le départ
[Applaudissements]
et pourtant au dernier relais tout le
stade est debout lorsque Piquemal passe
le témoin de le cours qui file vers la
victoire malgré le retour de l'allemand
Germain
c'est un premier pas vers la victoire
finale plus rien maintenant n'est
impossible aux athlètes français
oublions pas 4 mètres 55 à la perche
après l'allemand Uter au saut en
longueur brachi le français plus il pris
fort plus ils sont loin
[Applaudissements]
le 200 mètres c'est la réédition des
autres épreuves de vitesse on croit que
Piquemal va tout casser il sort du
virage en bolide mais pikma est trop
léger il ne résiste pas au vent dans la
ligne droite dans le courant encore une
fois remporte l'épreuve
[Musique]
de le cours Nantes pour la troisième
fois au fait du podium en 48 heures pour
le 1500 mètres les deux Michels Bernard
et jazzy se sont réconciliés ils ont
décidé de mettre les deux Allemands dans
leur poche pour jadis et facile il est
imbattable il le trouve en démarrant
quand il le désirent et s'il se retourne
plusieurs fois avant l'arrivée c'est
pour être certain que Bernard le suit
Bernard est là les deux Français donnent
le coup de grâce aux Allemands encore
tout surpris d'avoir été battu par la
France
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à Vénissieux monsieur Émile roche
président du Conseil économique à
inauguré le nouveau centre de recherche
des usines berliets à sa suite les
journalistes ont pu découvrir ce qu'on
ne verra pas au Salon de l'Auto le
laboratoire où c'est labore les nouveaux
modèles le temple futuriste ou 600
chercheurs soumettent au pire tyrannie
dans des cellules insonorisées les
organes mécaniques des prototypes en un
mot l'univers de robot et de cadran où
naissent prêts à prendre la route les
modèles de demain
ce qu'on ne verra pas non plus au salon
mais ce qu'on vit nous reporter ce sont
des voitures en action on serait tenté
de dire en vol
une nouvelle formule de présentation qui
se révèle parfaitement apte à démontrer
les vertus de maniabilité et de sécurité
d'une voiture
moniteur de l'école française de
haute-voltige élève du champion du monde
j'en suis José Kanga a fait ainsi la
démonstration qu'il est très facile de
rouler en Simca 1000
réputé gros mangeur de pain le Français
a également pour la science solide
appétit il en consomme 325 kg par an
soit près d'un kilo par jour et ça dire
qu'il s'est découvert une prédilection
pour les plats de clous non bien sûr
mais il s'est trouvé bien d'autres
occasions d'augmenter sa ration
quotidienne sous forme de monnaie par
exemple les nouveaux centimes seront en
acier inoxydable la pièce de 5 centimes
c'est le sous-dotrefois mais en acier
sous toutes les formes qui agrémentent
le confort quotidien cuisine tout acier
par exemple et puis les transports les
wagons ultra modernes qui pour leur
élégance leur propre thé et la sécurité
du voyageur ont été construits en acier
inoxydable le paquebot France à lui seul
a absorbé 34000 tonnes d'acier soit les
trois quarts de son poids total
et puis le bâtiment ou l'acier de plus
en plus utilisé
c'est le gymnase de La Porte d'Ivry
où la nouvelle faculté de droit à Paris
deux exemples parmi tant d'autres qui
traduisent la parfaite adaptation de
l'acier à l'architecture moderne enfin à
origny-sainte-benoît dans l'Aisne les
silos à blé comportent les cellules de
stockage en acier les plus grandes du
monde et l'on prévoit que l'appétit du
français pour l'acier augmentera encore
dans les années à venir
la plongée sous-marine ne date pas
d'hier mais les appareils préconisés au
XVIIe siècle qu'il s'agisse du
scaphandre de Borély ou des systèmes qui
ont suivi ne permettait pas d'excessifs
audaces ce qui n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui ou certains se lancent à
l'aigrement par 40 à 50 mètres de fond
pour la première fois des médecins se
sont réunis pour se familiariser avec
les conséquences possibles des plongées
sous-marines ils l'ont fait en devenant
eux-mêmes au Centre international de
bindor plongeur sous-marin si n'importe
qui peut songer à effectuer des plongées
sous-marines encore faut-il s'y être
entraîné c'est à cette nécessité que
répond l'école de bindorre qui est la
seule du genre et qui enseigne les
rudiments de la plongée par exemple
savoir sans s'affoler enlever son masque
le nettoyer le remettre la follement dès
qu'on a quitté la surface et le pire
ennemi
les grandes plongées du reste ce sont
des plongeurs expérimentés qui les
réalisent à 40 ou 50 mètres sous l'eau
l'aventure sous-marine en dépit de ses
apparences de facilité comportent des
dangers mortels principalement livraises
des profondeurs tout à coup le plongeur
perdant tout contrôle abandonne son tuba
la grande règle de la plongée est de ne
jamais l'effectuer seul une défaillance
solitaire est ici sans remède
quant au remontée elles doivent
s'effectuer par palier pour permettre à
l'organisme de rétablir l'équilibre à
mesure que la pression décroît
[Musique]
faute de quoi seul le caisson de
recompression qui reconstitue
l'opération manquée peut sauver
l'imprudent
il en est dans ce domaine comme dans
bien d'autres et pour qui sait garder
son sang-froid le monde sous-marin
réserve des satisfactions innombrables
la sensation d'une nouvelle liberté
[Musique]